I can't believe she just paid with this
thing like you just literally put your
hand up ice and you're good to go
hi my name is Charlie where's Elle I'm a
senior writer with BuzzFeed news and in
order to see what the future of money
looks like I decided to live for a month
I just paid for things with my phone and
somewhere along the line I ended up
getting a microchip implanted inside my
hand to see if I could be the first
person in the world to pay for something
out in the real world using just their
hand I basically wanted to try to
download as many apps on my phone as
possible and make sure that I could use
alternative currencies and try to skirt
Ashe or credit cards in any way possible
using your phone as a payment method we
call that a proximity mobile payment and
we estimate that by the end of 2016 US
adults will spend twenty seven billion
dollars using their phone at the point
of sale but you look at that in the
context and card volumes I mean that's a
pretty small drop in the bucket okay do
you guys you guys accept Apple pay or
any of like the card reader things for
your phone can't buy anything you're
right though okay all right thank you
very much when you're only using your
phone to pay for things and find that
you're sort of pushed to two extremes
really big chain stores or really small
niche and overprice coffee shops and
places like that a couple weeks into my
experiment I ended up going to Sweden
Sweden happens to be way far ahead of
the United States when it comes to
getting rid of cash I ended up meeting
with some people who are really active
in the biohacking community and found
that you could actually implant an RFID
NFC chip in your hand
so together deep breath me and exhale
and so I figured if I could put it in my
hand maybe I'd be able to pay for
something with my hand that was it yeah
how does it feel
it's like pinchy it definitely hurt like
way more than they said it was going to
it looks sort of like a grain of rice or
like a pill that's in my hand
I think the idea of using a micro chip
implant in one's hand to be able to make
a payment I do question the mainstream
application of it but I really think
there might be other ways where that
might come into fruition not necessarily
through like a surgical implant but you
know through other kind of integrations
with the body so once everything's
healed I decided that I needed to start
focusing on how to make this chip work
and I really wanted to become the first
person to ever pay for a meal at a
restaurant with their hand
eventually I stumbled across a venmo
engineer who said that he could help me
with my tasks what they decided is that
they would put my venmo unique user ID
onto my chip which would basically make
it so that any phone would recognize my
hand as a venmo app I'm gonna write your
secret token prevent oh you're gonna go
up there they're gonna scan your hand
but how much you owe that's it
here yeah sorry you're good to go
that was yes everything's a he actually
accomplished what was that to do and I
kind of couldn't believe that it was
ever gonna happen like I thought I got
this things jammed in my hands for
nothing my hand is paying for everything
if the wallet is here and your phone is
sort of a healthy middle ground
something like the chip felt to me like
the furthest possible extreme of you
know futuristic technology the challenge
of mobile payments is that it especially
in the u.s. it's so easy to use cars
after doing this experiment I would bet
that in about ten years it's kind of
abnormal to carry around a wallet that's
just stuffed full of cash that's insane
[Music]